okay what do you think what do you think
of the freaking live today
yo you guys can see our post thoughts yo
it was a it was interesting oh no the
the group show it was interesting
because
um
you ever notice how girls like you say
something when they make it about them
I'm like I don't know you I wasn't
talking about you yeah I I noticed that
about people and I've noticed that like
just throughout my life with friends and
whatnot and just like I brush over it
and I'm in my head I'm like I wasn't
talking about you but you clearly don't
understand that so and if I try to
explain to you you're still not gonna
understand it because obviously if you
knew I wasn't talking about you from
jump you wouldn't be saying the stuff
that you're saying right now and it
it was just interesting to see excuse me
it was interesting to see
just the reactions to certain things and
the
how they would how people would say it
they would say their things and they
would
hear other people react but they weren't
listening it's like people weren't
listening and so they say their thing
and they already have their reaction in
their head so uh the other person is
saying they're not listening to what
they're saying so when they say their
reaction it doesn't even make sense to
what the person would say and it like
would help them understand it better so
it was just like you know just listen
please
listen
and it's like okay
um and I I said this to the one on the
couch
I was like yeah that may be the
exception that may be a minute thing
and she was like yep oh yeah they both
have to over talk it was gonna say yeah
I'm getting better at telling them to
stop like I don't mind if you if you
don't do it intentionally yeah but it's
like when you when you've done it like
four times in a row I'm like shut the
[ __ ] this isn't your show yeah when you
were I was out there and I saw your hand
going
I said oh yeah it's almost time and then
they'll be like well you interrupted and
I'm like because it's my shot I can
literally you can interrupt anybody you
want
meal I have to interrupt because you go
on tangents like
I will let I will let you talk I give
people a lot of air time question
if I'm
if I'm talking yeah and I'm uh giving a
point blah blah blah and I pause for a
long amount of time
what is your natural reaction
you're done talking
that's all why
that's all
I just said what oh do you not I do not
understand why I asked you that
because the one that was sitting on the
other side of the couch she was talking
and she would pause and it it felt like
she wanted other people to react and
then she kept saying I'm not finished
and I'm like no it was like a power play
because she was mad that I told her to
shut up not to choose like she was
triggered so like she wanted to do it
back it was like a power play I'm asleep
yeah like that's that's why like because
like they're both pretty girls and like
pretty girls have gone through life and
they've never
they've never gotten a pushback for
anything because they're pretty girls
I couldn't believe she was 35 though
yeah
I said wow I said you look a lot younger
than 35 but
I thought she looks like late I had like
28 to 30. yeah no that's that's accurate
I just didn't think that I think yeah
she looks so fun I was like I give you
30. five years younger like you said
you're still suck and
I'm like you don't look 22 like sure I
just I mean it's not I'm not saying
you're not attractive like you're reckon
she had a kid
you think she again
oh no she did say that she um
she was alluding to the idea that I
wasn't on her cards or it wasn't
something she was like what happens is
girls they want kids and then they don't
find the guy they want to have kids with
yeah and they pretend they don't want
kids but they want kids
because if they were Barren tomorrow
they'd be devastated
[Music]
what I don't understand is why when
people are arguing or arguing a point
they go to the extreme where it's like
those are rare case and you go to the
extreme to make a point and it's like
you realize that that may happen one in
every million people and that's going to
be your arguing Point like
what is that
that doesn't make sense
Jesus
arguing exceptions to the rule can allow
you to win an argument in most scenarios
you're not stupid people yeah yeah and
it's only when you call it out then it's
it can't be argued because you've I'm
starting to get better at like calling
people's arguments out when I'm like
shame and solid guilt need to be like
because that's what they do when like
they'll be like I'm not shaming men I'm
like you you literally just did
like when you say things like um
I don't know what she said but if
something was shaming men for liking
younger women I'm like like anyone with
that mentality and I'm like well yeah
she didn't talk to me and I was just
like well like you're implying you're
better than them
oh man I don't know what you guys were
arguing I forgot what earlier yeah you
came and stopped it yeah I just I just
remember it was like oh it's like was it
between like a cow and an animal a baby
yeah he said something wild so I tried
to put him in his paper I'm glad you
just stopped it yeah I was just no I was
just like no no no we're not arguing
about this it was cool though I'm
excited about the book I hope I get it
yeah that was so here's my question to
you okay you questioned something and I
thought that was very really relevant
but then after that you're just excited
about the book
um
you said
you questioned what it was about and
then you realized it was like it was
four kids but then in the context of
what he was talking about it didn't seem
like the theme should have been for kids
after you read it you felt a bit more
I don't know if that was I don't know I
was because it it seemed quite dark it's
just informative but then he said it was
for kids and I was like
well it just depends how we do it I'd
have to see but
um his wife was so sweet actually he was
I was like you're a little sweetheart
he really was
yeah I'm in need with the women being
hypergamous would it go against your
nature to settle for a man that can't
measure up to your father
would it would it
would it go up against your nature I
would say yeah
will you read that again like I do I
think it goes up dependent on who your
father is to you I think he's talking
about me
no I'm saying like I think it does go
against your nature I do compare guys to
my dad
so it's unfortunate because my dad is
really great
uh so yeah I know I always compare guys
to my dad
um probably doesn't help me